so they've got three bottles there okay
three bottles and this is actually like
this happens all the time except for the
fact that it's probably not one liter
and usually be like 1.25 won it but just
for the sake of making the numbers bit
easier let's have a look at this okay so
there it is this is the example maybe
you want to follow along with me okay
you got your 500 mil bottle okay and
they say they're gonna charge us
seventy-five cents cents okay but
there's the other sizes which they'll
you'll pay different maths okay so you
got your 1 liter and I think that's it's
about 20 and then you've got your two
liter bottle which is two dollars fifty
okay now here's what's really
interesting before you shout out the
answer many of you'll be able to sort of
look at this and make a pretty good
guess as to which one it is without
doing any like write down maths because
we literally we do this all the time
right like we have to think about well I
just want to buy that much stuff for the
least amount of money right so which
would be most likely to be the best one
well Nancy I had the last one I think
there's a good reason to say that right
the reason why is because usually as
things get bigger they tend to get
cheaper why is that why don't I do that
oh why is Bob buying like why is it
cheaper you want to yeah yeah yeah
that's right they make you pay through
the nose and by the way in terms of
water that's a great example cuz you
guys know you like you know utility
bills right like if you've never looked
at your parents water bill do you know
what unit they charge like watering it's
mega litres yeah I mean you ladies in a
Megalodon I make a liter a kilogram is a
thousand grams right a mega gram is a
thousand of those it's a million a
million liters our houses use millions
of liters of water every quarter yeah
there's no taxes Awards why would they
talk about like GST okay no sorry I got
distracted yeah yeah what they are
trying to like the way they try to
encourage a behavior right if I'm making
something cheaper they want you to say
you know I'll give for that one right
rather than this one okay what were you
gonna suggest exactly right like it's
less in their interest to some one of
these because it's like I still got he's
left right so generally generally that's
why I put this here the biggest one is
the best okay but some of you might have
already noticed in this case it's more
yeah okay now all right now this is this
one that is actually the best price but
how can we explain that and not just
show it
okay so suggestions Peter okay so you're
saying if I were to get these two
equivalent right like get two liters
worth of 1 liter bottles now actually in
a cheaper than just getting one - they
were right how do you know this one is
not the better option either
it might be so how could we check yeah
okay so two of these is a dollar fifty
so you know it okay so here's the way it
works right
two of these bottles are equivalent in
capacity to this right but it's more
expensive bad you write two of these in
capacity equal to this and they're
cheaper right does that make sense okay
so therefore I just to do it one more
way it'd be nice if I could compare all
of them okay so what I'm trying to do is
they're my something very similar if I
get the same amount in all three sizes
okay here's an example if I wanted two
liters of 500 millibars
that'd be four of four of these right
two liters and that'd be that'd be three
dollars okay we already worked out this
one two liters of one liter bottles do
you already told me that was a 240 and
this one you don't have to do anyway
it's 250 so clearly now you can see now
I can make an equivalent comparison and
that's kind of what you were doing
mentally even if you didn't write down